[Musica]
vi è mai capitato di sentirvi persi in
mezzo al caos di tutti i numeri che ci
vengono somministrati ogni giorno parlo
di statistiche indicatori trend
ultimamente poi vanno particolarmente di
moda beh a me capita spesso di sentirmi
spaesate di perdermi un po in mezzo a
questo caos soprattutto quando quando mi
viene chiesto di trovare un senso a
questo caos oggi con voi mi piacerebbe
parlare proprio di questo provare
immaginarci un senso all'interno del
caos dei numeri ma vi parlerò di un solo
numero del numero uno è il numero di
partenza che il primo che incontriamo
diciamo nella nostra formazione è il
primo dei numeri primi è un numero che
rappresenta l'unità del secolo tutto è
addirittura c'è qualcuno che dice che
rappresenti sia il punto di partenza che
il punto di arrivo
beh se ci pensate il caos comincia a
originarsi nel momento in cui ci si
allontana da questo uno di via che
cresciamo infatti aggiungiamo numeri ci
allontaniamo dall 1 e aumenta la
complessità conosciamo nuove formule
nuovi numeri indicatori funzioni
logaritmi e dietro questa complessità
nel momento poi in cui si diventa adulti
e si cresce si comincia a ritenere che
la complessità sia il l'ingrediente
magico per riuscire a risolvere i
problemi
è come se fossero tanti numeri
l'ingrediente fondamentale la somma
degli ingredienti fondamentali necessari
per raggiungere gli obiettivi e appunto
risolvere anche problemi complessi
diciamo che io non credo che sia così
del tutto e mi piace poter condividere
con voi questo pensiero raccontandomi un
po il mio viaggio nei numeri
che è partito diverso tempo fa perché
ormai sono vent'anni che analizzo dati
di bilancio né analizzati milioni di
questi bilanci
ho costruito sistemi di misurazione
della performance anche complessi
sistemi di rating di scoring ho
costruito nuovi indicatori ho cercato di
fare in modo che questi dati di bilancio
mi raccontassero tutto quello che ci
fosse da sapere di un'azienda volevo
capirne l'essenza
e dietro questa analisi continua
incessante vi dico anche stimolante
mi sono accorta che per spiegare
veramente un indicatore per coglierne
l'essenza appunto e poterlo poi
raccontare a chi ti commissiona
l'analisi agli studenti che ti stanno
ascoltando in aula sia necessario
conoscerne la genesi devi
sostanzialmente tornare a un punto di
partenza quell 1 iniziale senza
conoscere il percorso dei numeri è
difficilissimo poter raccontare quella
che all'evidenza sostanzialmente nel
caso dei bilanci poi ancora più evidente
perché chi di voi li dovesse conoscere
ma bene o male rientrano nel patrimonio
di quasi tutti sono report numerici che
raccontano la vita di un'impresa però
riferita al passato si riferiscono
sempre a un esercizio chiuso come si
dice in contabilità a un anno a un
periodo già concluso e io per raccontare
questi numeri inevitabilmente dovevo
tornare indietro dovevo tornare a quello
iniziale
ho avuto poi un sostegno un alleato in
questo diciamo in questo viaggio ho
trovato un faro in mezzo alla nebbia
caos dei numeri e questo faro è
rappresentato in particolare
dall'analisi dei cosiddetti migliori
cioè dalle migliori aziende
agli analisti come me viene spesso
richiesto è un classico un must viene
richiesto di analizzare interi settori
economici e di estrapolare quelli che
sono i dati la lista dei migliori del
settore è un classicone te lo può
chiedere un centro studi te lo può
chiedere un imprenditore dice caro mi
sai dire cortesemente chi sono i
migliori all'interno di un settore
benissimo
prendi tutti i bilanci di tutte le
aziende che operano all'interno del
settore
le analisi cerchi il set
la lista delle variabili che meglio
possono spiegare lo stato di salute di
un azienda e poi comincia a filtrare i
dati di solito il migliore risponde
simultaneamente ad una serie di
indicatori positivi che raccontano lo
stato di salute di un'azienda vedi ad
esempio il trend dei ricavi
la marginalità la liquidità il livello
di indebitamento bene ti presenti dal
committente con questa lista
sei riuscito finalmente ad estrarre la
lista di queste imprese
chi guarda il committente dice ottimo
ora una lista mi dici però una cosa come
ci sono riusciti
ecco il faro come fai a spiegare
solamente con i numeri come ci sono
riusciti i numeri sono un sintomo è
l'evidenza del fatto che un processo sia
si sia concluso positivamente quindi
inevitabilmente ho cominciato una sorta
di processo a ritroso sono dovute
entrare nella vita dei numeri nel loro
percorso per ritornare indietro e
comprende tornare a quell 1 iniziale
sempre il nostro numero di partenza e
quindi ritengo che questa tipologia di
analisi spero di essere riuscita a
restituirla in maniera abbastanza
semplice sia stato per me un po il
volano il punto di partenza e questi
migliori nel momento in cui li hai
davanti e ti devi chiedere come stanno
con me hanno fatto deve inevitabilmente
un po abbandonare i numeri ed entrare in
una logica più qualitativa e scopri
una serie di indicazioni non banali e
ritorni a quell 1 che cos'hanno in
comune mediamente le aziende migliori a
prescindere dal settore in cui opera
bene le aziende migliori mediamente di
donna medio ovviamente rispondono quasi
tutti a un unico input unico eco sono
tutte figlie di un sogno che ha trovato
concretezza
di solito le imprenditrici o gli
imprenditori che ricadono poi nella
lista dei cosiddetti best sono bambini
ex bambini che continuano a giocare
continuano a gettare coerentemente non
scendono a patti su tutta una serie di
questioni non tagliano per guadagnare
hanno un'altra attitudine
tendenzialmente sono come eravamo tutti
noi quando si giocava si stabiliscono le
regole
io le porto avanti fino alla fine
maniera coerente ecco i migliori fermo
restando che sicuramente hanno per darvi
qualche elemento accademico ottimi
risultati in termini di crescita del
fatturato ottimi margini ottima
liquidità debiti buoni pagano
addirittura di più i dipendenti di
solito nelle aziende dei migliori si
lavora volentieri c'è un buon clima si
ricevono addirittura dei beni fit quindi
non si lesina sui costi una infatti
delle caratteristiche diciamo sempre in
una media quelli che io ritengo
veramente migliori e di non tagliare per
guadagnare per darvi un senso quindi
quest'analisi per me è stato
fondamentale mi ha aperto proprio gli
occhi ha dato un senso anche a quella
che poteva essere la mia attività di
consulenza presso gli imprenditori
perché così riuscivo a qualificare
quell'informazione ben però preso a
tutto questo patrimonio informativo cosa
succede invece mediamente nelle aziende
intorno a noi quelle che non richiedono
nell'olimpo dei migliori attuano tutti
questo tipo di logica
no per mia esperienza vi posso dire che
tendenzialmente le decisioni
vengono prese a posteriori e sumeri che
non soddisfano
immaginiamoci un'azienda che sta
funzionando non una start up a
un'azienda neo costituita come funziona
arriva un report che racconta quello che
è successo nel mese precedente nel
semestre precedente o nell'anno
precedente si guardano i numeri non
soddisfano si ritoccano i numeri con
calcoli complessi divisioni e
sottrazioni per cercare di far sì che
questi numeri poi la volta successiva
diano qualche risultato positivo quindi
sottrazioni e divisioni ma queste
sottrazioni divisioni che cosa può che
cosa portano portano inevitabilmente a
rimaneggiare ad alterare quella che è la
gestione aziendale e anche la cosiddetta
visione aziendale perdi il senso
dell'unitarietà perdi lo scopo verdi
quell 1 iniziale quei chi sei quake iii
sono il tuo sogno
questa è la prassi media che cosa si può
fare quindi che cosa vi posso raccontare
in questi pochi minuti ma che spero vi
lascino un messaggi di valore qual è la
formula magica cosa dovremmo fare tutti
noi pianificare trovare quell 1 fare in
modo che quell 1 sia il punto di
partenza è anche il punto di arrivo
so che sembra un po filosofico ma spero
vi arrivi il senso perché c'è molta
matematica dietro quell 1 come punto di
partenza pianificare tutti i numeri per
ritornare in un sistema circolare a
quell 1 al tuo scopo la pianificazione
consapevole avere chiaro chi sei e
quindi come vuoi essere conosciuto e
pianificare i numeri noi con la volontà
di piegarli diciamo così a delle mere
formule mattie di harley al tuo
desiderio e al tuo sogno
qual è il tuo obiettivo qual è il tuo
sogno come veramente vuoi realizzare il
prodotto il servizio quindi che
servono che costi vorresti portare su
questo come vuoi pagare i tuoi
dipendenti quali benefit gli vuoi
offrire dove deve essere la sede ci sarà
giardino la palestra l'asilo la mensa
quali dovrebbero essere gli utili che io
desidero al netto delle tasse che devo
pagare si chiama processo reversibile
io pianifico tutti i numeri e dopodiché
mi chiedo e quindi quale deve essere il
prezzo
so che qualcuno mi potrebbe dire facile
in realtà lo è perché se pescate nella
memoria dei casi di successo che tante
volte vengono anche acclamati dalla dai
media
spesse volte non abbiamo a che fare con
imprese che combattono sul prezzo sono
imprese che in maniera molto disinvolta
porta il prezzo che ritengono opportuno
sulla base di una serie di dictact che
sono coerenti rispetto al sogno del
dell'imprenditore quindi questa la
soluzione la soluzione è trovare il
proprio uno e rimanere coerenti rispetto
a quello trovare il sogno del bambino è
infatti è la mia missione quella che è
diventato poi è il mio lavoro
insegnare e fare consulenza è cambiata
da quando ho acquisito consapevolezza su
questi elementi perché non porto più
solo tutti i numeri che conosco e tutte
le complessità ma porto prima di tutto
quello no sia i miei studenti che magari
diventeranno futuri imprenditori o
futuri manager sia gli imprenditori con
cui lavoro il primo giorno si parla di
quello noce lai chiaro quell'uno sai
qual è il tuo scopo riconosci il bambino
interiore dentro di te e il sogno il
gioco che vuole portare avanti perché un
business si pianifica dalla testa non si
corregge dai piedi e l'unico modo per
dare valore e scopo al business è
proprio questo
trasformare la propria iniziativa nella
realizzazione di un sogno
questi elementi che sembrano
probabilmente molto romantici ma veri
petto trovano accoglienza vino
numeri arriva aiutano anche l'impresa
stessa a raccontarsi in modo nuovo non
so se conoscete nei 4 p del marketing
mix
oggi si parla addirittura di una nuova
pen che è prato inglese
lo scopo perché se tu hai uno scopo e
fate sempre
ricordatevi quelle che sono le nuove
idee di business vincenti non parlano
solo di prezzo e di caratteristiche del
prodotto parlano dell'obiettivo
dell'imprenditore lo scopo il segno che
vuole lasciare e non è un fattore da
poco poter arricchire il proprio
messaggio con quello che è lo scopo che
ti sei prefissato il tuo sogno portare
sul mercato
il tuo sogno e raccontarlo ne puoi
raccontare pezzettini e puoi fare in
modo che addirittura i tuoi dipendenti
escano dall'azienda e parlino benissimo
di te lo riconosceranno i clienti non
riconosceranno i dipendenti lo
riconosceranno i fornitori
perché quando si ha uno scopo sia una
specie di luce magica che ci pervade e
molto spesso nella contrattazione ci
capiterà da consumatori capita anche a
livello business to business tra aziende
nel momento in cui la componente scopo
nel marketing mix è forte il prezzo
perde di significato un po perde di
potenza non si sta più a guardare al
prezzo del prodotto del servizio si
cerca qualcos'altro si porta a casa un
pezzettino di sogno di
quell'imprenditore e questa è la formula
magica semplice applicabile da ognuno di
noi
la difficoltà sicuramente per quello che
lo porto come primo elemento perché
inutile chiedermi di correggere i numeri
dai piedi quando so già che l'unico
sistema è quello di passare da una
pianificazione consapevole dalla testa e
aver chiari propri obiettivi è trovare
quell 1 iniziale e spero che questo
viaggio seppur breve ma intenso perché
io lo sento fortemente e vi sia piaciuto
vi lascio chiedendovi e augurandovi più
che altro di trovare il vostro uno di
trovare uno scopo è di realizzare il
vostro sogno grazie
[Applauso]